je prends beaucoup de refus et
et là bas je fais le tour un peu tous
les magasins et ça c'est compliqué que
ce soit pour payer ses études son permis
ou encore ses vacances de nombreux
jeunes recherchent chaque année un petit
job pendant l'été une tâche devenu
difficile il demande de l'expérience de
minimum 2 ans pour être dans la vente
que ce soit agents de caisse ou mise en
rayon donc forcément quand on est
étudiant et qu'on n'avait pas eu le
temps encore de faire ses premiers jobs
étudiants c'est compliqué d'avoir cette
expérience là quoi j'ai beaucoup de mal
à en trouver j'ai fait quelques quelques
travaux quelques travaux bénévolement
et puis j'ai enfin trouvé là un travail
chez une grande enseigne qui recrutent
beaucoup de l'étudiant pourtant avec la
réouverture de nombreux commerces et le
retour en présentiel des entreprises
charlotte bec coordinatrice de l'indh et
29 centre d'information jeunesse des
yvelines reste optimiste là elles vont
se retrouver aussi avec une humble moins
de main-d'oeuvre assez important et
elles vont pas pouvoir se permettre de
d'augmenter leur niveau d'exigence est
un moment quand on a de la main d'oeuvre
et des gens qui sont volontaires et
dynamiques pour ça moi je pense que ça
c'est ce sera assez payant pour les
jeunes outre les plateformes internet de
nombreuses structures existent pour
aider les jeunes dispositif municipal le
pôle jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux
organise un mois thématique pour
accompagner les jeunes à trouver un
travail cet été l'équipe du pôle
jeunesse va accompagner donc les jeunes
sur la réalisation de cv et de lettres
de motivation
ils vont comment dire partager avec eux
les sites qui peuvent les aider
justement à trouver un job d'été
et puis surtout sur les événements vous
savez de job dating y en a eu un certain
nombre parce qu'il n'ya pas que vendeur
serveur ou saisonniers ces structures
peuvent également orienter les démarches
vers des métiers moins habituel